vous savez pendant longtemps j'ai cru ne
pas être réellement à ma place très
jeune j'ai eu envie de partir en fait
c'est comme si je pensais que dans
d'autres cultures dans d'autres espaces
un paradis existait quelque part un
paradis où chacun pouvait s'exprimer et
s'émanciper alors dès que j'en ai
l'occasion je suis parti d'abord vers le
grand nord les grandes forêts boréales
puis vers le grand sud le pacifique et
plus récemment j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer l'afrique où j'ai posé
définitivement d'ailleurs une partie de
mes valises sur mes routes j'ai vu des
paysages magnifiques
j'ai vu des cultures charismatique
également j'ai vu des personnes qui
m'ont énormément inspiré mais j'ai
également vu des atrocités
j'ai vu le système néolibéral étendre
ses tentacules jusqu'aux endroits les
plus reculés de la planète amenant avec
lui bien sûr son lot de modernité et
d'espoir mais également son lot de
craintes et d'injustice je n'ai pas
trouvé le paradis donc mais j'ai trouvé
quelque chose d'autre qui ne m'a plus
lâché dès lors la passion de la
diversité qu'elle soit naturel ou
culturel et surtout des relations qui
peut exister entre les deux une chose
m'a particulièrement bouleversé la
dualité entre nature et culture que je
croyais être la norme
car elle est pratiquée chez nous
n'existe pas dans de nombreuses cultures
en amazonie dans certains villages
africains les humains échanges avec les
non humains comme au fond avec des
frères des soeurs des amis des ennemis
aussi parfois en tout cas se dégage je
crois de ces territoires
une certaine poésie où tous les êtres
vivants sont unis dans une même
communauté de destin
ses voyages ses morceaux de vie que j'ai
eu la chance de vivre à droite à gauche
mon invité aujourd'hui apporter une
sorte de regard nouveau sur les
problématiques composent nos sociétés
j'ai aujourd'hui dans les réflexions que
je porte une hypothèse forte je me dis
que finalement les crises sociales les
crises environnementales qu'on connaît
prennent en partie leur source dans la
dualité qui caractérise la totalité nos
façons d'être et d'agir
la dualité entre nature et culture car
je crois que cette dualité donne au
progrès une vision uniforme celle de
l'accélération une accélération
économique d'abord lorsque chaque
entreprise et sommés d'être plus
compétitif que la voisine une
accélération sociale lorsque les
jeunes de ma génération la génération y
veulent accéder à ce sentiment de vie
éternelle
la vie éternelle c'est pas forcément à
être immortel c'est en tout cas essayer
de vivre un maximum de vies en une seule
vie aux périls dans vivre réellement
aucune et puis enfin je crois une
accélération paysagère lorsque les
territoires sont considérés trop souvent
dans les politiques publiques uniquement
comme une simple variable d'attractivité
mais pire que l'uniformité cette
modernité amène en société de nouvelles
précarités auquel je pense nous devons
tous et toutes être très vigilant car
construire la modernité sur un monde
dual d'abord c'est instrumentalisé tous
les êtres vivants à des fins sociales et
économiques construire la modernité sur
une seule vitesse ensuite se laisser sur
le bas côté
tous les êtres qui ne peuvent ou ne
veulent suivre cette vitesse en disant
ça je pense notamment aux minorités
je pense aux villes petites et moyennes
qui sont aujourd'hui complètement
phagocyté par les emprises
métropolitaines
je pense aussi aux non humains qui ont
une temporalité complètement différente
de la nôtre
ce faisant l'humanité va perdre une
valeur qui devrait pourtant tous nous
unir
celle de la diversité car je crois que
la diversité est capable de créer de la
richesse en se concentrant uniquement
sur nous-mêmes on se rend plus compte
que les humains ne sont plus les seuls à
pouvoir créer des mondes des castors
peuvent modifier les cours d'eau par
exemple les arbres créer un écosystème
propice à leur pied et surtout tous les
être je dis bien tous les êtres sont
vulnérables et c'est bien les relations
que nous construisons au quotidien des
relations que nous construisons avec la
diversité qui permet de survivre face à
cette vulnérabilité
mais mieux encore je crois que la
diversité est capable de créer de
nouvelles trajectoires d'émancipation
pensez par exemple à la rencontre entre
un humain et un chien cette rencontre et
d'un résultat qui est largement
supérieur à la somme des parties
autrement dit un humain en plus un chien
ça ne fait pas de l'amitié rajoute 1 3
le dialogue rajoute 1 4 les souvenirs
ajoute à 5
bref il ya un monde de relation qui se
crée un monde de relation qui est propre
à ces deux individus plus d'intelligence
donc mais également plus de bonheur il
ya de nouvelles études qui sortent
aujourd'hui par les plus grands centres
universitaires qui montrent que c'est
bien la qualité des relations
nous construisons quotidien qui
participent le plus au bonheur des
individus
aujourd'hui je me prend modestement mais
je me prends quand même arriver à un
monde axé sur ces relations est possible
je me prends à rêver que un dialogue
davantage symétrique entre le nord et le
sud entre les humains et les non humains
est également possible et c'est
notamment dans ce cadre que nous
essayons petit à petit de forgé le
concept d'écologie relationnel
relationnel car il s'agit de remettre au
premier plan de l'action et la pensée
les relations qui nous unissent les uns
aux autres et écologie parce que parmi
ces relations
celle qui nous unissent à la nature à
feu doivent prendre une place
prioritaire une place primordiale mais
le mieux je crois pour vous raconter
l'écologie relationnel c'est de vous
emmener de nouveau chez moi en afrique
de l'ouest
lors de mon dernier voyage au burkina
faso une de mes tantes pulpart alliance
amina tard m'a offert cet objet une
calebasse qu'elle a fabriquée elle même
de ses mains et qu'à la pinte d'ailleurs
elle-même deux sèvres
si je me permets de vous montrer cet
objet ce soir c'est parce que il permet
de comprendre un monde qui est
complètement différent du nôtre
je m'explique si je devais expliquer cet
objet comme les oxydes comme l'éducation
pardon occidentale me l'a appris au fond
je dirais que je vois un récipient qui a
été fabriqué sûrement avec une courge
que ce récipient sert sûrement apporter
des aliments en l'occurrence du lait
comme c'est d'usagé dans la culture
peule et qui peut également servir à
décorer des maisons et je crois que je
m'arrêterai plus ou moins ici mais
maintenant si j'essaye de comprendre cet
objet à l'aune de l'écologie relationnel
autrement dit si j'essaye de comprendre
cet objet par toutes les relations qui
lui ont permis d'exister
je vois au fonds beaucoup plus de choses
les étoiles et les triangles que pouvait
voir sur le sur la calebasse sont des
symboles de la culture peule les étoiles
pour guider les bergers lorsque le
désert lorsque la nuit pardon recouvre
le désert
les triangles qui symbolise également la
fierté du peuple peuls meeple sur un
peuple très fier la fierté du peuple
poehl à construire ces évolutions
sociétales
mais mieux encore comme je le disais
tout à l'heure cette calebasse est
rapportée du lait et les peuls sont
devenus au fil du temps maître dans
l'art d'élever des vaches
d'ailleurs les vaches revêtent une
dimension symbolique très forte dans
leur culture
il ya un adage qui dit qu'un peu le sens
troupeau c'est un prince sans couronne
mais imaginez pour pouvoir élever des
vaches aux portes du désert
cela demande une très bonne connaissance
du vivant une très bonne connaissance du
cycle de l'eau très bonne connaissance
des cycles du sable également une très
bonne connaissance du fonctionnement des
animaux autrement dit des connaissances
qui se crée sur plusieurs générations
des connaissances qui dépasse de loin
intemporalité d'une seule vie humaine
c'est bien là je crois la première
invitation de l'écologie relationnel
c'est au fond de nous permet de nous
amener à une méthode qui nous permet de
comprendre le monde par les relations
qui soude qui nous unissent les uns aux
autres ce faisant il ya je crois deux
intérêts le premier c'est de mettre en
crise les limites des sociétés
occidentales et le deuxième encore plus
important je crois de redonner de la
légitimité à des sociétés qui ne vivent
pas comme nous dans l'afrique dont je
vous parle ce soit la maison de retraite
s'appelle la famille la maison de
retraite s'appelle la famille mais
davantage qu'un mode pour penser
l'écologie relationnel c'est également
une nouvelle voie pour habiter la terre
mais échanges récents avec aminata lors
de mon dernier séjour au budget au
burkina faso ont montré que certains
objets issus de la modernité qui
s'impose dans ces territoires remettent
en cause la capacité d'une société à
vivre comme elles le souhaitent au nord
du burkina faso actuellement s'impose un
lait concentré sucré industriel venant
de chine de hollande entre autres et qui
se vend à des prix défiant toute
concurrence sur les marchés locaux
contre ce lait des femmes des hommes des
enfants même parfois manifeste justement
avec des calebasses
mais ce faisant ces personnes ne
manifeste pas uniquement contre l'entrée
d'un lait de mauvaise qualité dans leur
territoire elles manifestent contre
toutes les relations que met en péril ce
lait l'apprentissage réciproque des peu
envers leurs troupeaux des peuls envers
le désert mais peu en verlan ancêtres
autrement dit ces personnes défendent la
singularité de leur monde contre
l'uniformité du nôtre cette calebasse
que je vous ai amené ce soir ce n'est
pas seulement un objet d'artisanat c'est
une véritable lutte politique et au fond
ce que nous ce que nous apprennent
aujourd'hui c'est d'une politique c'est
également de décentrer l'action de ne
plus se concentrer sur l'autonomie des
individus comme c'est d'usagé depuis le
siècle des lumières mais se concentrer
sur les relations qui nous unissent les
uns aux autres et surtout sur les
relations qui nous unissent
au milieu en remettant par exemple bien
vivre au coeur des constitutions en
permettant à chacun de vivre de manière
belle juste et libre dans le territoire
qui l'a choisi en développant le
télétravail par exemple c'est parfois
pas si compliqué en donnant également
des droits à des lieux de vie des droits
des territoires il ya je crois des voix
de sagesse qui reste aujourd'hui
complètement inexploré construire cette
société de la relation ça peut commencer
tout de suite maintenant à notre échelle
pour cela un seul mot d'ordre tout
simple remettre du lien là où il n'y en
a plus allons tous qu'est chez notre
voisin par exemple allons partager notre
tiramisu n'importe quoi qu'on aime faire
d'ailleurs avec ce qu'on apprécie avec
ceux qu'on aime
plantons des plantes de partout de
partout en ville comme en campagne il
faut qu'il y ait de la nature de partout
dans nos vies ils ont également aussi
davantage d'éthologie d'anthropologie de
géographie ça demande un réel effort
réel effort de comprendre l'autre pour
ce qu'il est et non pour ce qu'on
voudrait qu'il soit voyage ont aussi
davantage contrairement à nombre de mes
frères et soeurs d'écologie je suis de
ceux qui réhabilite le voyage car sous
certaines formes le voyage c'est une des
seules manières de se confronter à
l'autre de se confronter à la diversité
et puis quand le changement individuel
est venu il s'agit de construire des
collectifs à l'échelle territoriale
artistiques politiques citoyens les
entreprises privées même pourquoi pas
peu importe mais l'idée de ces
collectifs c'est de jouer sur la
structure même du système en mettant en
mouvement les différentes énergies
individuelles
je crois personnellement qui a pas de
grand soir en écologie il est encore
moins de grands soirs en écologie
relationnel mais une multitude de petits
gestes parfois très ordinaire de forme
mais qui quand on sait les observer
revêtent une dimension extraordinaire
celle de construire un monde qui puisse
enfin abriter plusieurs mondes
je vous remercie